this is the beginning of our fourth week
and you believe it fourth week of shows
from quarantine four weeks of shows
without laughter actually no that's
about seven months of shows without
laughter we've had a rough patch there
for a while
now come on just getting around Bob
Odenkirk saan the show wonderful program
are you probably wondering about this
look I'm just trying to find different
things to wear night tonight to kind of
break it up I just found this in this
closet I was shocked too apparently
three years ago I won the Masters anyway
terrific show as I said a lot to do got
some jokes for you I know you like your
jokes here we go watch this just fresh
in from the writers keep those writers
work and keep them busy check this out
Los Angeles mayor Garcetti say he may
cancel sporting events until 2021
yeah LA Kings fans say they're fine with
that
zing got him hey check this out my
nephew is bummed that he's gonna miss
senior prom yeah I would feel bad for
him except that he's a 31 year old gym
teacher kind of changes the story lets
you find that out huh yeah he's a creep
I like this one Tyler Perry Tyler Perry
isn't this sweet he surprised thousands
of senior citizens by paying for their
groceries isn't that nice yeah
however Tyler did insist they called him
Tyler Perry's groceries I'm sorry I like
that one okay hey if I'm laughing that's
half the battle